the crepitude decline Frailty disease
disability loss of cognitive function
and those are abnormal things that
happen they don't have to happen
it's possible to be very vibrant if we
know how to take care of ourselves and
what we've done in our culture is
activate all of our disease systems is
the ability to slow the rate of aging
and then reversing aging that has
occurred possible now it's just hiding
in tens of thousands of scientific
Publications and a lot of really hard
work what we see as aging today is
something that gives us an impression
that it's bad to get older because
you're going to become disabled decrepit
dysfunctional frail